We want it to really kick it off with a taste of what the magazine is like.
So we're going to hear a quick reading from Gary over here who was a contributor
to the first issue.
Um,
and he's going to read you a part of his contribution to the magazine.
Woo.
Well,
I'll be reading expert excerpts from my piece.
Call it depression on the art that safely
I was 14 when I first felt the urge to and my own life.
Most mornings I would wake up feeling cold and unwanted.
Even in the spring when the Dogwood tree outside my window blossomed.
I struggled to find beauty in the world to motivate myself to get out of bed.
Although there are spurts of happiness,
my teenage years were haunted by the desire to call it quits.
I struggled with my emotions,
but more importantly,
I struggled with why.
Why did I feel those urges?
Why was I unhappy?
For years,
I tried answering these questions.
I'm wondering if my parents,
rocky marriage,
where my failed two week middle school relationship factored into my depression
as I,
as I entered high school,
however,
I began to realize that these contortions of the mind,
we're rooted and an internal struggle with my race and my identity.
I grew up in a predominantly white community.
Why?
I surrounded myself with white friends.
I ignored our differences in race and fundamentally our differences in culture.
I and I sacrificed and an important part of myself to blend in among my peers.
I ate different foods at home than I did at school.
I was annoyed when my parents mispronounced basic English words.
Yeah,
I would shamelessly laugh when white students made mocking impersonations of
other Asians.
I wondered whether my true self was the person I was at home,
the person I was at school or neither.
I remember a time when I was flipping through movie channels and lingered on a
Jackie Chan film,
a scene where he was distressed and exclaimed and a heavy accent.
Who am I?
What's branded in my mind for years?
Who am I and major challenge of my depression was desensitization in order to
cope with suicidal thoughts.
I large largely ignored them.
I sat my emotions aside and put on a plastic smile wherever I went.
Over time,
not only did I become an expert at hiding how I felt inside,
but I also became incapable of letting my emotions flow for years.
I never cried despite how desperately I begged to,
I lost the sensation of being human and felt completely out of touch with my
emotions.
One summer during high school,
my dad dropped me off on the National Mall in Washington DC.
Go explore.
He said,
has he drove off to work?
I load the experience.
I wanted to spend my summer at home playing call of duty or aimlessly scrolling
through Facebook.
After a few days wandering through museums,
natural history,
airplanes and design.
I eventually stumbled into the Hirshhorn,
a Smithsonian Museum dedicated to modern and contemporary art on view was an
Yves Klein retrospective highlighted by monochromes and blue impressions of the
female body pulled across canvas.
Searching for meaning in these paintings sparked a sense of curiosity and what I
would later discover to be a sense of purpose.
I devoted the remainder of my high school years to pursuing my fledgling
interest in the arts to see how far I could take it.
Fortunately,
my parents supported this move because they thought it would make me a unique
candidate when it came time for college applications.
In fact,
the focus shifted from making sure I had good grades and Calculus and
Statistics,
so allowing me to curate my identity around the arts in order to stand out from
the Asians who had perfect sat scores.
I roll enrolled in AP art history and subsequently an independent study,
but something was still missing.
Academia bored me.
I was never satisfied simply reading about it.
Plus,
for however much I loved art,
studying art at a suburban high school for the jocks still ruled supreme.
It was perceived as less than cool.
I continued living as an outsider,
not fully in the Asian community and not fully in any other.
Even as I pursued what I loved,
I still felt alone at Duke University.
That sentiment persisted into my sophomore year.
It was the only,
I was the only male art history major and the only minority in my class.
Even though I had found a group of likeminded individuals,
I couldn't get over how different I was on the surface searching for an escape.
I proceeded with the only millennial thing to do and I created an Instagram.
It became my diary.
My Instagram at art drunk began as a means to document artwork I liked,
hated,
and everything in between.
Ultimately,
I realized there was an outlet for communicating my emotions,
but I posted in this digital world often reflected how I felt in real time and
in real life.
Posting a Lucho Fontana,
Italian artists known for slashing into canvases reflected one of my troubled
moments and my connection with the rawness of breaking and otherwise perfect
surface posting.
A Richard Serra and American sculptor known for massive expanses of steel
reflected how I enjoyed feeling human again under a towering walls of metal and
knowing that it would exist centuries beyond my life as my Instagram following
grew,
so did my sense of purpose.
Although the challenges of being Asian American and a white community and the
additional struggle of being a minority in the arts have made me feel different.
I believe that my race does not define me.
It is only a part of my identity rather than the whole of it.
I continue to engage with my heritage,
learning about different Asian teas and being proud to hear Taiwan become the
first Asian country to legalize gay marriage,
but through our,
I'm empowered to push beyond stereotypes as helped me create an identity for
myself,
not restricted by the color of my skin or the way my eyes squint when I smile.
My battle with depression lasted seven years,
which transformed the way I viewed the world and the people around me.
There was seven years,
took me down a road where I thought the darkness,
we never turned to light,
but eventually there's seven years brought me into my foremost passion.
Through the struggle I found art and in a very real and literal sense,
art safe me.
Without it,
I would still be lost.
Trying to understand what it means to be different and what it means to be me.
Thank you.
Yeah,
thank you so much.
That was awesome reading and we're going to get to hear from Gary about that
piece
an upset.
Okay,
perfect.
All right,
I'm excited to introduce our panel here today.
I'm just going to do some quick bios.
We have some context.
Um,
directly to my right
is uh,
our two founders Catarina and Christy Catarina is a product status strategists
in the tech industry and has worked,
uh,
from companies actually ranging from like Yahoo too early stage silicon valley
startups.
She's passionate about music,
um,
about topics like making topics like race and identity,
easier to talk about in our everyday lives and has a bachelor's of arts in
English and music from Cornell.
Christy is a creative strategist at Landor a global brand consultancy and serves
on the national advisory board of answer a sex education nonprofit that provides
pro bono consulting services to women led organizations.
Uh,
she is an avid storyteller who hopes to one day perform at the moth and hold the
dual degree in business administration and public health from UC Berkeley.
Um,
Tessa is actually the creative,
sorry,
what was the marketing director?
Head of digital head of digital?
Yes.
Sorry.
Head of digital.
The person who like knows what Instagram photos are coming up from this event.
Essentially.
We planned that out earlier.
Um,
she spent the last five years here at Nyc putting her marketing degree to use.
We actually talked at lunch about how she's the only one of us who actually used
the third degree.
Um,
and uh,
currently leads luxury marketing and uh,
for the ad sales department at the Wall Street Journal as well as heading up the
digital efforts at slanted.
Um,
also perfecting column making skills,
which was pretty awesome.
He just heard my Jewish husbands.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I will.
I personally know that Asian Jewish pairing is let's Drago and
um,
and then Gary,
who we just heard from is a business analyst at,
for the CIO at Fiserv lending solutions and an aspiring art collector.
As you heard from his peace,
you can also follow him on Instagram at,
at art drunk.
Uh,
so check that out afterwards as well.
But I think I wanted to kick it off kind of a hearing first of all from our two
founders here about sort of what you,
how you would define like what slanted is and what inspired you to found it.
Yeah,
I can sort of tell the origin story.
So slanted is a media company that celebrates Asian American identity through
personal storytelling.
And it came
about because Kristy and invited me to a Facebook group called project boat,
which was just a place for people to Asian Americans to post about what's going
on in the news,
ask for advice and just have a community of likeminded people.
And I saw all these amazing stories happening,
but they were happening in this private Facebook group and I was like,
this needs to be out into the world.
So I was like,
Hey Chrissy,
you want to start a magazine?
And we had like a humble spreadsheet where people were just dropping an ideas of
what stories they might want to contribute.
And then from there we launch our Kickstarter campaign in June,
which got such amazing support and that funded the issue one which is on sale
today.
Um,
and then for the launch party for issue one,
we really felt just such an amazing sense of community.
Like we had a sold out launch party.
The energy and the support was just so incredible.
And at that moment we were like,
this is way bigger than a magazine.
So we decided to be a media company and explore new forms of media in 2018.
Awesome.
And a big part of that too is a,
I went to a book talk with Eddie long about six months before a slanted became
something and he said that if spaces don't exist for you,
kick the door down and create them.
Um,
and at that time we didn't even know this was going to be a thing.
and when cat reached out to me,
it just felt like the right opportunity because we didn't see ourselves in media
or in mainstream media.
We wanted a place where we could share our stories from everyday people.
So one of the big things about slanted is that it's not celebrities who write
for us.
You know,
it's not published writers per se.
It's people like you,
me,
your brother,
your sister,
your cousin who just have a story to tell and they just want a place to share
that and to connect with other people.
So Santa,
it's really supposed to be a community building creative outlet for all of us.
Um,
all of us were friends when we started this.
So I think that's what makes it extremely special.
Definitely.
And so,
I mean,
touching on that point of the idea of like building a community.
I feel like one thing we talk about with the Asian Googler network a lot is that
there is very little consensus on what it means to be Asian American.
Um,
you know,
that term encompasses in theory like hundreds of different like ethnicities and
languages.
There's also the question of,
you know,
citizens and noncitizens residents of the US who are impacted by issues that
affect the community,
but you know,
may not have been here as long or may not be here forever.
How do you guys sort of define that idea of American Asian American identity?
For the purposes of the magazine?
So for the magazine we define Asian American as anyone who has come from Asia,
so including East Asian,
southeast Asian and South Asian and there are a lot of different groups and our
goal is not to sort of lump everyone into one category.
It's more to celebrate the differences that we all have and the shared
experiences that we do have.
I think one thing that the Asian American movement is getting better at is being
in solidarity with each other because in the past we've been very separated.
Just thinking about our history in America,
coming to America,
no ethnic group wanted to associate themselves with another ethnic group that
had already come because they want it to not face those same,
the same discrimination.
But now like I feel since the 90s and coming into the two thousands we're really
starting to come together and a realizing that together we are stronger and we
can make a difference as a,
as a one whole collective.
Yeah.
And being this like hyphenated culture has been an interesting thing for us at
slanted because,
uh,
when we edit a lot of the pieces from issue,
one of very common theme was straddling two worlds.
So straddling what it's like to be Asian,
what's like to be American,
not fitting in either place.
Um,
and that's something that I think we wrestle with individually and collectively
as a community.
So when we look for contributors,
we're looking for people who are exploring this question of what it means to be
Asian American.
Um,
it's not at 50,
50 split,
it's just an ongoing journey.
And everyone on this team is also going through a sense of self discovery in the
process.
So when you were crafting this first issue of the magazine,
how did you go about sourcing different voices and different parts of the Asian
American community?
So it was a pretty grassroots effort.
We had a Google form that we just sent out to friends and family.
Great way of collecting information.
Um,
and from there we made sure that every piece had a mission,
that the author had something that they wanted to say to the community.
And the theme of our first issue was beginnings.
So whether that's a spiritual beginning or self awakening or the start of
something new,
we wanted to make sure that every piece related to the theme
and we purposely tried to keep it very open.
Um,
you know,
it's a very interpretive for each person and we looked to sort of get people
from all over the country.
So although we're in New York City right now with,
you know,
on this event,
our contributors come from all across the country.
Uh,
we had 21 for this first issue and we actually only need seven of them
beforehand.
Um,
we don't know how they found us.
I think it was through word of mouth,
but that speaks to the solidarity of our community.
Just looking for a place to share their stories.
Hm.
Interesting.
Um,
Tufts,
I know we were talking earlier about,
you know,
balancing the fact that you guys have put so much work into launching this while
also having these amazing careers in tech and marketing and all of these other
things.
So I'd like to hear from all of you,
I guess about,
you know,
what it's been like balancing a passion project and starting a new media company
with having these full time at other jobs.
Yeah,
I mean it's a lot
like the journal was going through a Reorg at the time that things were really
ramping up and like I was planning my wedding and we were launching this and it
was like,
there were times where I was like very stressed out.
But I think that this is a situation in which the phrase passion project is
really very applicable because like some of my friends and I have like started
projects where we were really into them,
but like they never really went because
you know,
like if things came up it kind of took a back seat.
But this is like the kind of project where for me it meant something very
personal.
So I was able to kind of prioritize it over certain other things because it
meant so much to me and it meant so much to everyone else who is doing it.
Um,
I was actually talking to Gary about this this morning.
I feel very lucky.
Then I hit my quarter life breakthrough,
uh,
shortly before starting slanted where up until then I kept thinking my job had
to be my calling,
had to be my passion.
How did you met everything?
Um,
and then I realized that it didn't have to be that it didn't have to put so much
pressure on my job being something bigger than what it really was.
Um,
and so I happened to land a job a nine to five that truly was essentially a nine
to five.
Um,
and I love what I do.
I love doing branding and the company is really supportive of me doing side
projects like this.
And so the epiphany of having a job that supports me in the way that allows me
to do something like slanted or pursue a passion project is really pivotal.
Uh,
we joked that slanted is like a second job.
Um,
and I definitely would not have been able to do it if it wasn't for us,
for my current company.
It was a good pivot there cause I was like,
oh,
she's like,
oh yeah,
it's not really a passionate of mine.
Nine to five,
five to nine for sure.
A very,
very loving piece of like my five tonight.
Right.
I can't imagine any other team to do this with either.
I think the passion that we all have,
the personal drive is right.
A really big factor.
So what kinds of things have you done to sort of raise awareness of the magazine
and go out and spread the word that there is this new voice in the landscape?
I think right now most of it has been word of mouth,
which just is a testament to how strong the community is.
Um,
our biggest channel right now,
it's Instagram.
I think us being millennials,
it was a natural outlet for us to speak directly to our audience.
But in the new year,
in 2018,
we're going to be looking at events hopefully across the country.
Um,
more marketing on social media channels and paid advertising as well,
and also just cocreation or collaborative events,
um,
or even initiatives.
So,
uh,
we've been very active about going to other events,
meeting people,
not just Asian Americans,
but other communities of color,
uh,
to see what types of events they're interested in,
what kind of dialogue they want to be a part of,
and how we can really raise awareness in that way.
Because something we discovered at the launch party was that this isn't just for
Asian Americans.
Like we are a platform specifically to elevate the Asian American narrative,
but it's a broader immigrant story.
Mm.
Um,
and in that sense,
I think we have
power to really make a stronger impact by collaborating with others.
So has your idea of like,
what representation looks like changed as,
as you formed the magazine?
Or what,
what do you see yourselves highlighting or we're really elevating thematically
in the future?
I think so.
So one thing that was an interesting shift is when we first started slanted,
we thought we would create a community to bring like minded people together.
And then after the election happened and seeing the divisiveness within our
country,
we realized that we don't need to bring similar people together.
We need to bring different people together and people with different
experiences,
cultural backgrounds and perspectives and show that even though you are
different,
you can still be friends.
And in the end we all share the same fundamental stories of being a human.
I think it's also kind of like a cultural movement that's happening that we are
just a part of.
Um,
I think that you can see that and like Hollywood where the people speaking out
against like the white washing of Asian roles and traditionally Asian movies or
like the Hawaii five o casts like walking when they weren't paid equally.
Um,
just all sorts of things like that are really coming to the surface now.
And I think that's what makes our platform especially relevant and especially
like needed.
Yeah.
Has that been like a big reaction from people?
Is that specifically they talk about Hollywood whitewashing or representation in
media when they talk to you guys about what they want to see.
We do get a lot of questions,
like anytime we talked to press about things going on on a media,
um,
but it's interesting because we,
it's not just about that,
like the story is so much larger and we're just one piece of the puzzle that
needs to happen in order to push the movement forward.
Also,
because we're rooted in personal storytelling.
So the questions that we get are the topics that we get fished for,
um,
are a little bit deeper than that.
I mean,
they definitely cover representation in media or lawsuits per se.
Um,
but one of the things that really struck home for us was,
um,
a lot of reaching out from families who adopt Asian kids and to their families.
Oh,
and that's a story that personally I haven't explored yet.
Um,
I would love to explore in future issues,
but just these open questions about what do we do?
How do we talk about race and identity with our kids who grew up looking
different than us?
Um,
and so it's a very sensitive piece to talk about.
but I think that's something that we can do.
We can create a safe space for that conversation to have.
That's really interesting that that's kind of the audience that's surfaced for
you guys.
Do you have,
do you feel like you have a response for that or is there kind of a sense of
like,
well we can't define for you what your child's like Asian identity,
right?
Obviously that's a very big role to fill,
but I do think these everyday stories can help.
Like I'm thinking of when I was growing up,
did I have a magazine that I could pick up and read about other Asian American
experiences?
Um,
I didn't really have anything like that.
So this could be slanted,
could be something for that loan kid in Arkansas who might not have a community
that looks like him or goes through the same experiences that he does for him to
pick it up and say,
wow,
there are other people that can relate to what's happening to my experience
as long as act as a resource.
So like we're definitely not the authority on it,
anything like the Asian American narrative per se,
but,
um,
every time we talk to someone they get so excited and want to connect us with
five more people in the community.
So maybe we can't speak about that story in particular,
but maybe we can connect them with someone who can put them in touch with
someone else or share their own story.
Definitely.
So in that sense,
what has been your vision of like,
I know you were saying you actually decided to become a more full rounded media
company rather than a magazine.
Is that where the idea comes from?
Is creating resources?
Um,
not necessarily just for resources.
I think it's to expand the reach and realizing that stories come in many
different shapes and sizes and forms.
Um,
we've gotten so much clamor about digital.
I am a die hard paper Fan,
but I do recognize that in the 21st century,
digital is really critical.
They can both work together,
they can work together.
Um,
so figuring out how we can create more platforms for storytelling because we
were created to fill a need and we can't just fill that need with paper or with
print.
Right.
Also the fact that we want to create a community that has a two way dialogue.
So whereas putting out a magazine and having someone consume it is more of a one
way conversation.
We really want to create spaces where people can interact with the content and
interact with each other.
Um,
and start to talk about these issues that are so complicated in nuance that
really need discussion around it in order to move things forward.
Yeah,
I think that especially today,
like if we are trying to reach that lone kid in Arkansas who like doesn't have
any Asian friends or like an Asian Asian community,
like an online presence that's robust and really a community in itself is so
important.
Right.
So it sounds like you guys do an amazing job of,
of kind of giving a voice to people like that who don't feel they have a
community currently.
But on the flip side,
like I was talking to a friend recently who mentioned that he really thinks of
himself more as Asian rather than Asian American and that,
you know,
if he wanted to see himself represented in the media,
he could watch Chinese movies and read Chinese books.
Um,
and do you see like a divide there between the experiences of more recent Asian
immigrants or maybe even non like non permanent residents who you know,
who are in the states for now?
Um,
versus like sort of American born or American raised,
um,
Asian Americans,
Asians.
I think there's actually,
from my experience has been quite,
quite a difference where I want to go into a school like Duke University.
There are a lot of international students and of course some from China,
some from Korea.
So I'm from the Middle East.
But I think the very nature of being international and not coming into a country
and having to find people that are like you,
they sort of group themselves off very quickly and they formed their own
communities.
And so whereas for me,
like being Asian American growing up,
um,
growing up in predominantly white communities,
uh,
I was much more,
not to say that they're not open to that,
but I was already sort of in those groups and in those communities.
Whereas there's definitely that divide between the two.
And I think for me as an Asian American,
it's almost difficult to,
to connect with other Asians from actually from Asia or born in Asia.
Yeah,
thank to that point.
And interesting chat,
like not a trend but a pattern that's emerged I think in our conversations and
in the stories that we hear is that like you have this unique position where
you're kind of like two Asian to be American,
but you're like too American to really be Asian to actual agent or to people who
live in Asia.
So being Asian American is this really interesting place to be.
And like for me personally,
when I was younger I like didn't want to have anything to do with it.
So I would like ignore all my Chinese homework and I like hated my Chinese
lessons.
And now I don't know how to speak Mandarin,
which I really regret.
So if I were looking for more Asian representation in media,
like I wouldn't be able to watch Chinese movies or like read Chinese books,
I would just,
I'm looking for Asian representation like in American media.
So I think it's a really unique thing to you and like how deep your connection
is to your Asian heritage.
Okay.
I think part of the divide,
the sum of the cause potentially could be,
we gravitate towards people who give us a sense of belonging.
And so,
um,
as Asian Americans,
maybe we'd gravitate more towards Asian Americans because we get the traditions
after observing or the food that they're eating.
Um,
and people coming from another country,
potentially they can't speak the language and they feel a sense of belonging
within a specific group.
And so it almost feels like a sense of survival tactic in this in a way.
Um,
I would love to break down that divide and we've talked about the hierarchies
within Asian American culture.
Um,
that's something we definitely want to explore because again,
Asian American isn't just East Asian.
And so what does that hierarchy look like and how we can start to break that
down and to really connect on a more human level,
right.
Beyond race.
Yeah.
And I think that would be the ultimate goal is to break down that barrier
between Asian Americans and Asians.
Because if we're all living in,
in America,
then we can all benefit from having a more solid community.
Do you see any value then in doing like multilingual content or you know,
having people from lots,
all these different ethnic and language groups who are contributing,
doing stuff that's maybe like translated in both languages or anything like
that?
That would be amazing once we have the resources to test this point.
Like I personally can't read Mandarin Chinese.
I would love to be able to another regret also going to 10 years of Chinese
school and not studying hard.
I would love to able to translate that cause we've gone and actually inquiries
from folks who don't live in the u s oh,
interesting.
So we were trying to figure out as a startup,
like how do we ship to another country,
um,
how do we translate things in other language?
But that would be amazing if we could do that.
I think to,
to that question,
I don't know if any of you guys saw the most recent show at the Guggenheim.
So it's an exhibition on Chinese art.
Um,
and I think as someone who appreciates art and has studied art in school,
I was really surprised to find how different it was to look at art.
That was,
you know,
we,
we see a lot of tech start,
but tech start that was Chinese Chinese-based and based off of Chinese
characters.
And that gave me a really new approach,
a new found appreciation for what art could be.
And uh,
if we did have stories in different texts,
obviously at different languages have different nuances to the actual,
uh,
word.
Uh,
like there are a lot of words we can't express,
uh,
in Chinese that we do it express in English and vice versa.
And so if there are ways to actually integrate that,
that'd be great.
Okay.
Yeah,
no,
that's really interesting.
I mean,
I definitely see the challenge.
I also don't seek any checks.
The editors,
it's like,
how do we edit this in a different way,
right.
Very big deal in my family that I took Japanese in college and stuff,
so.
Right.
Don't you have a Hashtag
hashtag about it.
Um,
Gary,
kind of like speaking to,
you know,
your art experience and stuff.
Like how did you actually like first come to get involved with slanted and like
how did you choose that piece?
I was like,
what you wanted to contribute for this first issue?
Yeah.
So,
so my sister Lena,
she,
she's actually involved with the founding of slanted.
I think she was the partnership director.
She's a hustler and chief handled a lot of the partnerships that we had.
Yeah.
And so she,
I guess when they,
they're looking for contributors a nationally,
she just reached out to me.
Um,
and I signed on.
That's,
that's the story for that.
But,
uh,
in terms of the actual piece,
initially I was going to write about being a minority in the contemporary art
world where there are honestly aren't that many,
especially in scenes like New York and London.
It's hard to find Asians who are at the top of the gallery chain or at the top
of being good collectors.
Uh,
so that's what I thought about,
but I mean tests,
sorry,
Kat.
Kat and Chrissy can really attest to this where I really struggled with that
topic and I spent two months writing it,
sending back drafts and missing deadlines here.
Uh,
and eventually I wanted to write something a little more personal.
And this piece was sort of,
had always been on the back of my mind of accepting that I had a mental illness.
And I think writing it down really,
uh,
was that way of,
you know,
expressing,
this is who I am,
so be it.
I want to share that story and uh,
really try to just share it with other people who might connect it with.
And I thought that was an amazing shift because it was actually a completely
different piece than what we were first working on.
And mental illness is something that really isn't spoken about in Asian
communities.
So we have a couple pieces on depression and overcoming mental illness,
um,
in a very traditional household in issue one.
Yeah,
I completely agree.
I mean it's just not,
it's not considered acceptable and a lot of ways.
Yeah.
So have you had any specific reaction from readers about those pieces in
particular?
Oh,
about the mental health stuff?
A definitely a few folks.
Um,
one
of my old roommates actually is she,
she's very open about mental health and she's actually thinking about going into
becoming a psychotherapist.
Um,
and she read that piece and was really happy that she saw that piece,
like solid Gary's piece because she is excited about the prospect of people
coming to terms with that and being able to openly share that maybe they're not
done overcoming it yet and that they're starting to seek help.
Um,
and just seek a community to have that conversation with was really interesting.
but there are other seems within the first issue that really resonated with
folks to,
um,
there's one in particular about,
I'm an Indian American woman who renounced her Indian citizenship to take on US
citizenship.
Oh,
interest.
And she talks about that struggle all her life growing up,
wanting to be American and wanting to go to prom.
I owe it to driving a range rover with their friends going to the mall.
And then finally when it comes down to it and she has to renounce her Indian
citizenship,
uh,
she feels this overwhelming sense of sadness that she has to let go of a part of
a culture,
a part of herself that for a long time she was pushing aside.
Um,
and it doesn't matter what race you are.
Like being able to let go of something from the past to handle a lot of
something in the future is really interesting.
Yeah,
definitely.
I mean,
I already wanted to read this because like,
that's something my family actually went through.
My mom was originally Malaysian and after my sister was born,
she was like,
Oh,
I guess I'm staying,
but had to renounce citizenship for that.
Um,
so in terms of,
you know,
the more beyond like community building,
I feel like,
you know,
it's almost like a political act to create an Asian American magazine because
there has been so little media attention around like the Asian American
community.
Um,
do you guys see yourself as like a political force in some way?
That's an interesting question because when we first founded it,
I would say no.
But now I would say it's inevitable.
And I personally,
and I know a lot of the people on the slant and team has been really aware of
just the words that we use,
making sure that everything we say is politically correct.
Being educated and reading up as much as we can on Asian American history and
what our people have been through.
Um,
it's just inevitably tied to the political sphere.
And so I think all of us are on that journey to becoming more politically aware
and president.
Hm.
Yeah.
And everything is political these days,
but they're not as much as you say something or don't say something.
It's political.
Um,
and I think,
you know,
our name is really bold and I think that's important to recognize because we're
going to be unapologetically bold about these stories.
And I think in year two we're really looking to do that a little bit more,
you know,
finding stories that really pushed the conversation,
uh,
to be a platform for Asian Americans,
not just about Asian Americans.
Uh,
so yeah,
I would say that we could be a political force and the community behind us to do
that.
Right.
Do you find the community sort of divided?
I mean,
I think my impression of the Asian American communities like the,
we have so many different issues.
Like you know,
for instance,
you know,
Southeast Asian members of the community face very different issues in terms of
like racial profiling and stuff than East Asian.
Has it been hard to,
to create like a unifying force or a unifying voice in that sense?
I think that's something that we're going to be working on for years and years
to come.
Like,
we're still not there.
And it's about both celebrating all these differences and the different maybe
stereotypes that each group might face.
Um,
the different experiences that we all might go through and saying that even
though we have all these different experiences,
we can still relate to each other.
Um,
can you talk a little bit about,
you mentioned the,
the choice of the name for the magazine.
Yeah.
It's funny because we didn't think it was so controversial until we actually
pushed it out there and we get comments about it all the time.
Um,
but there's,
there's a couple different meanings behind it.
One that I love to talk about is we really want to shift people's perspective.
So putting a slant on something or putting a tilt on something and getting
people to see things in a new light is really what the name saint it is about.
And the fact that it's unapologetically bold and we want to spark those
conversations.
Our Name is definitely a conversation starter and something that leads to deeper
Um,
another thing you had touched on earlier,
it's like the nuance and the diversity of the Asian American communities.
So the term slanted is often used as a blanket term,
uh,
to characterize all Asian Americans.
Uh,
but that's not fair because the origins actually come from East Asian features.
Um,
so what we wanted to do was reclaimed this term and to actually make it a term
that we can celebrate.
Um,
and so that's a little bit about what we are about,
which is celebrating Asian American diversity and identity.
So we wanted a name to characterize that and when we first started actually half
the team was not onboard with this name.
Um,
there we had funny names,
we had it all cutesy names,
a lot of food related related ones.
Um,
and now I don't even think twice about it.
Now.
I love that term so much.
I don't even think about the derogatory nature of it.
And I think that speaks a lot to what
we're trying to accomplish.
Did you follow it all that there was a lawsuit related to this name?
Yeah.
Does anyone want to explain more context on that?
Essentially there is like this Asian American rock band called the slants and
they were trying to trademark their name and um,
the patent and trademark office wouldn't allow it because they said it was
discriminatory,
discriminatory towards Asians and they were like,
but we're Asian and we want it.
So like isn't this a freedom of speech situation?
And eventually,
and it weirdly happened to be at the same time of launch,
the supreme court ruled in their favor and the favor of the slants so that they
could have that name trademarked and take back ownership the way that we are.
But it was so funny cause everyone was like,
have you heard,
is this from the same thing?
And we're like,
no,
it's like purely coincidental but I think,
you know,
it kind of,
it just even,
it provides even more support for it because it's,
it's just like the universes.
Yeah.
The university in that favor.
And actually
it was funny because we want to say that we're friends with them now because we
support each other.
We talked about them on our Instagram.
They gave us a shout out as well.
I think it's again speaking to the power of the communities that when you find
something or people who understand what what you're going through or they just
get it,
um,
there's like an unspoken relationship
ship there that I think keeps blossoming.
That was interesting.
I remember thinking of the case itself is really interesting as well because you
know there was this freedom of speech idea of like well are you allowed to
reclaim this term?
But I did see someone bring up alternatively that because the supreme court
decided in favor of that band that also the Washington Redskins get to keep
their name as well.
I have a double edge.
Yeah.
It's interesting cause I was like rewatching this Trevor Noah segment on it last
night where the patent office basically told the slants like if you weren't
Asian you would be able to trademark this name.
But because you're Asian it gives the con the discriminatory context and the guy
who was like hosting the segment,
it was basically like,
so in saying that like this is a,
like they're trying to protect you from racial discrimination.
They discriminated against racially.
How does that make sense?
Yeah,
the world's a crazy place.
Right?
It's so funny.
Um,
so what about um,
you know,
kind of transitioning from the Redskins away from horrible UN-PC things too.
Like how do you guys feel you've been trying to reach across the aisle to maybe
other minority groups and stuff as well?
So I think that's where our partnerships partnerships come in.
We've been going to a lot of events and meeting other people of color in this
space and figuring out what we can do next year to create more community spaces
that are inclusive of all races.
Yeah.
Specifically I was telling the team over the weekend about people of color and
solidarity storytelling event that I had been to in Brooklyn of course Brooklyn,
um,
two weeks ago.
And it was interesting to have a conversation of what people of color really
means a traditionally,
and these personally,
I never felt like I fit into that category of a person of color.
And it was actually hosted by folks who have Latin American roots and they had a
very interesting take on this too.
They were quiet for a lot of the session,
a lot of the storytelling session.
And one of them came forward and said,
I'm sorry,
I'm so quiet.
Um,
it's because for the first time I'm realizing that I wasn't including Asian
Americans in this conversation.
I wasn't including them in this conversation of what people of color really
means.
Um,
and I really appreciated that honesty and that vulnerability.
And that's something that we believe in too.
And I think it's good for us to keep ourselves accountable and honest.
And when we say Asian American,
what does that mean?
And when we say immigrant story,
Um,
I think it's going to be a constant learning opportunity for us and a great way
for us to see honest with ourselves.
Do you see that separation of the Asian American community from other people of
color as like imposed on us by other groups or something we impose on ourselves?
Um,
I imagine it's both.
Yeah.
I think,
you know,
there's all the stereotypes about Asian Americans,
right?
That were quiet that we don't like to speak up for things.
We stay in the foreground or the background.
Um,
I'm seeing every day that that's changing.
I mean,
and again,
there's a piece in our issue,
one that talks about the political uprising of Asian Americans were,
a lot of times folks in the government ignore us as a voting group.
They don't think that we like to vote,
um,
that we have a voice.
And so they oversee us or they neglect us.
Um,
you know,
so some of it may be true a little bit where we're not going to be speaking up
as much as we would like,
but I think that's changing.
And I think given the election and this fire that we've all been lit underneath
us to do something is really changing that course.
Tell us a little bit about like,
you know,
you chose this theme of like beginnings for the first issue.
I'd love to hear a little bit about,
you know,
what that means to you and also what you kind of see as being the next theme
going forward.
So beginnings was a natural theme for us because it was issue one.
So this was sort of the beginning of what slanted was,
but I think for a lot of the team,
it slanted was a creative outlet for us to explore our own identities.
I know for me personally,
I grew up in a predominantly white community and I didn't start thinking about
my Asian American identity until after college,
which is crazy because all of my formative years have already passed.
So for me,
slant has been a personal awakening of discovering who I am and my cultural
heritage.
And I think a lot of the team was along the same vein.
They were discovering something about themselves too.
Okay.
Yeah,
I mean,
beginnings for me was interesting too because I grew up in the opposite
situation where my neighborhood was predominantly Asian.
My high school was 64% Asian growing up.
So I never felt like a minority.
I went to Berkeley,
which was also full of Asians.
It wasn't actually until I moved to New York about three years ago,
uh,
that I felt like an other,
or I felt like a minority,
which to I guess not New Yorkers seems kind of crazy.
It's such a diverse place.
Um,
but you know,
the conversations I was having with friends,
a lot of whom are in the audience today,
I'm talking about our different experiences really made me realize that all of
our beginnings are so different,
but we share a lot of values and I really wanted to explore that with this
project.
Yeah.
I think also the theme as you'll like read the pieces and the issue,
uh,
beginning mean something different to everyone.
So it's not even,
it's not even necessarily like the beginning of you like welcoming your heritage
or realizing that you know,
you do fit in or you don't fit in.
It's like beginning to form a tight relationship with your mother or like the
beginning of when you first immigrated to America.
It means something different for everyone.
And I think to be able to explore that was really cool to see how everyone
interpreted it.
Have you ever had any negative feedback from people?
Yeah,
definitely.
Um,
as you said,
like whether we intend for it or not,
everything is political.
So we've gotten negative feedback about our name,
um,
pushing the envelope.
Um,
but you know,
even it's not as much negative as it is constructive criticism.
So we are very open to feedback and we definitely ask people that we talked to
as mentors,
as visors,
as friends,
and tell us how we can up our game.
Um,
and so with a content perspective,
people really liked how relatable it was,
but they were like,
well,
given how bold your name is,
could you push the content a little bit further?
Um,
are there any other topics that you could explore?
And I think that's great because we're so new and we're so open to the evolution
and just,
you know,
we've only been around for less than a year,
so I can only imagine what's going to happen
years two to five.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's another thing that I would love for slanted to work on is the fact that
we do get constructive criticism shouldn't stop anyone from talking about race.
Like it is very scary to talk about race.
You always need to be politically correct.
You know,
you need to be educated about what's going on,
which oftentimes prevents people from being open about talking about it.
But if we don't talk about it,
we're not going to get anywhere.
So we really need to make it more accessible for people to talk about these
really difficult things and just be confident in where they are in their own
journeys.
Definitely.
Um,
let's take a question from over there.
Thank you guys so much for coming.
It's truly inspiring.
I will 100% be purchasing.
My first issue.
I was just thinking is the perfect gift for my little sister.
She's also half Asian,
so like similar to me.
Um,
no really.
but um,
my question is kind of about the right at the story gathering piece and how you
guys actually get,
um,
stories.
Do you guys,
you know,
just wait for them to come in.
Do you guys put certain posts out and you know,
on top of that,
how does it,
um,
choosing the stories to go with a certain three theme?
What does that process like?
You want me to start?
Sure.
Um,
so,
you know,
like Kat said,
we love Google.
We literally live and die off of Google.
So we use a Google form to collect story ideas.
Um,
a lot of the stories actually didn't end up the way they started,
which we think is a really beautiful process and we want to do more of that next
year actually workshopping the stories with people.
Um,
but we asked for an idea,
we ask again for their objective,
what they want to achieve with it,
what's the key message.
Um,
and to get the word out,
it was friends,
family and fools and posting it in community groups on Facebook.
So,
you know,
going into Asian American interest groups,
posting on there,
you know,
project boat,
which we initially started as a support group,
alumni networks,
basically anyone that we thought would,
might be interested.
Um,
the first two weeks were very slow.
We were really worried that we weren't going to get anyone to contribute.
Um,
and I don't know,
something just happened.
I think word of mouth,
you know,
it's a very grassroots movement.
And again,
out of the 21 contributors,
we only need seven of them beforehand.
So it's,
we're hoping that next year is probably a little bit more strategic in that
sense.
Hopefully our name is a little bit out there and we can come out to events like
these and meet more people who'd be interested in sharing their stories.
Definitely.
Thank you.
How should reach you if
they see this talk for example on our youtube channel and they want to be a part
of it.
Yeah.
So you can visit our website@slanted.media and we're opening the submission
window for issue two in January.
So you can either send them to our newsletter to get an update or just find us
on social media.
We'll be very loud when the window opened.
And so,
you know,
to come and submit your story.
Is it all,
I'm like sort of personal essay pieces or are there like poems,
journalistic pieces,
anything like that?
It's a variety.
So we have short stories.
Just kidding.
We don't have short stories.
We have short pieces.
We have how it tree photography,
art.
Um,
it's,
it spans all genres.
Anything that can be printed.
Awesome.
Um,
what about over here?
Yeah,
I just want to say thank you again for sharing your piece.
Gary.
Like I was very touched by it.
Um,
I'm a Chinese psychologists so I feel very strongly about raising awareness for
Asian American.
So I was wondering if you guys have any like plans or needing contributors or
like,
you know,
um,
ways to kind of bring the awareness to the general community.
Cause I,
you know,
I think we all know that,
um,
Asian Americans tend to,
solve problems in their own house and like,
I think,
um,
needing to reach to them,
it's still like there's still a huge gap.
So it was wondering if you have any thoughts on that?
Uh,
yeah.
I mean,
I think we're exploring that,
but again,
we're a creative platform,
so how could we explore the difficult topics of mental health from a creative
perspective?
So could we host writing workshops or,
you know,
town hall discussions about this?
I think,
uh,
we can't do it alone and we're definitely not experts in this field.
So we would love to partner with people who have experience in the mental health
space to help us create some,
a place that's safe.
Um,
you know,
that's irrelevant and meaningful for these people.
Yeah,
I feel like being,
being so involved with the arts,
I've realized there's a lot of artists and a lot of creative types that have
mental illness and I,
I don't know if they go hand in hand,
but,
uh,
when I first posted my story on Instagram,
I've,
I was really surprised by the outpour outpouring of support,
uh,
an interest in these sorts of stories and a lot of direct messages just saying,
Hey,
this is,
you know,
thank you for sharing this.
Uh,
I've dealt with depression myself.
My sister's dealt with depression,
depression,
whatever it may be.
They all had their own stories.
And again,
I think this is a great platform to,
to actually get the word out and,
uh,
with peripheral topics like mental illness,
this is again,
a good grounding and foundation for,
for those discussions.
I have a car,
couple questions about,
uh,
contributing.
The first one is,
uh,
I just visited an Asian American lit class,
at a high school yesterday and they were all really engaging writers.
So I want to know if there's an age limit to being a contributor.
We have not put an age limit.
Um,
it's something we could consider,
but right now anybody is open to con to submitting.
And then so along
with that,
does that mean that you have to identify as Asian American to contribute?
That might be an obvious question,
but maybe not.
So all of our issue,
one contributors were Asian American,
but we would be open to all any race contributing as long as it aligns with our
mission.
And aligns with the theme of issue too.
There.
I think it depends on what the narrative.
Yeah.
Hmm.
And I think too,
you know,
you bring up a good point about talking to potentially a younger audience.
Um,
the team struggled too.
We tried to figure out who is our target audience.
You know,
Asian American is so big.
Um,
so millennials were obviously an easy target because we're all millennials.
But there are so many interesting stories coming out,
um,
from high schoolers and even younger.
And so how could we go into universities and high schools to have this kind of
conversation?
So we would be really interested in meeting people and the younger demographic
to see what issues they're dealing with and how can we give them a space to
share that.
All right.
Thanks for being here.
And uh,
good luck on your,
on all do the work you're going to be doing.
Um,
so the,
the topic about translating submissions reminded me of a story of my grandfather
started an academic journal in Korea about I guess nearly 50 years ago now.
And when he started it,
he just simply wanted,
um,
people to submit articles written in English so that people outside of Korea,
academics,
I'll set a Korea,
could read it and understand what's going on.
Um,
so I guess it just brought one thing is that there's so many different agent,
uh,
I guess American languages that English is just happens to be a uniform,
something that is in common.
So,
um,
I guess sometimes things get lost in translation and maybe the,
if the submission is written in the language they're most comfortable with,
um,
and,
but,
uh,
that might be ideal,
but I hope,
I guess for maybe the majority of people it would be,
I guess just English.
Um,
and,
um,
the second question I had,
do you guys do anything with like the museums,
like the Museum of Chinese American and things like that in this city?
Yeah,
we actually had our launch party at the Museum of Chinese America and we're
stock there as well.
And we're definitely looking to partner with other museums and other Asian
American organizations.
Yeah.
And,
um,
came,
what was your first question?
Oh,
it wasn't more of a question hearing about,
yeah,
just how like is simply my grandfather also started,
I guess,
something like a Zeen back in jail for political science articles.
It's,
it's called a Korea observer and it's like,
you know,
all the articles in English.
So that's his,
cause he wanted the audience to be broader than just,
you know,
people and create,
just so you know.
So everybody,
yes.
I think that,
um,
topic of translation has really interesting and like obviously something that
we're excited about exploring,
but we don't want to,
we want to be able to do it right.
We,
you know,
we want to be able to do the pieces justice because if it is lost in translation
then like what's the point in it?
I'm doing good.
Good luck with it.
Thank you.
Awesome.
Um,
I think we didn't actually touch on like thoughts for the issue like Oh
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
funny you ask because we just had our kickoff over the weekend to start thinking
about issue too.
Gotcha.
Um,
we haven't narrowed on a theme yet,
but our creative team did a really great job in the prompt.
So the prompt was wishes and wonders.
Um,
so thinking about reflecting on this past year or almost a year,
what do we wish we had covered?
Um,
what are we wondering about still today about race and identity?
And there were a whole swath of different options.
We had stuff that was very universal to like what they call,
like the dark horse theme.
Very,
very niche,
very,
very specific.
And a little bit controversial.
Hmm.
Um,
I think,
Huh?
Your rock,
your wax,
what?
Yeah,
it's a wide range and I think we're going to land somewhere in the middle.
I think,
um,
you know,
we want a theme that's universal enough that people can interpret on their own
and make it their own.
Um,
but we also want something that's not generic.
And I think two things that we're looking for in this next round is as Christy
mentioned,
pushing the envelope a little bit.
So because these are everyday stories,
how can we elevate them and make sure that they're worth the buzz and worth
sparking those larger conversations.
And another thing is making things a bit lighter.
So is one was leaned on the more heavier side,
which is normal because the experiences that we've had that we face,
so the Asian Americans are on the heavier side.
But how can we bring a sense of fun and playfulness back into talking about
these really heavy topics will be interesting for us to explore.
Yeah,
definitely.
Um,
we're almost at time.
So my last question is going to be,
you know,
we obviously want to sell us on those magazines in the back.
You guys,
um,
how would you pitch the magazine to a non Asian audience?
Oh,
it's a great question.
I mean,
I feel like
part of the appeal is that it's fun.
I don't know,
like I'm not explaining myself right,
but I think that like,
so my inlaws are not Asian,
but they were just so excited that I was doing something like this with my
friends and they were like telling all their friends and like they were buying
all these books.
And I think that just the fact that it's part of a movement that has pieces that
like everyone can relate to,
I think everyone can relate to at some point feeling like they don't belong
somewhere or wishing that they were different or connecting to their heritage.
I think that everyone has some sort of connection with what we're doing,
which in a way like helps sell itself.
I think it's anchored in human emotion.
Um,
you know,
there's themes about sacrifice,
about love,
about realization,
actualization.
Like these are themes that transcend race.
Um,
so I would say it's just a fun,
creative outlet for people to read stories and learn something about themselves
or learn something about another culture.
And who doesn't want to do
that in this day and age,
given what's going on.